I wanted to just ask about this loop
that I've heard a bit about the oldest
and loop okay what is it well Isis it's
a good register right then we've
unfortunately you emailed me and asked
me about this beforehand and I thought
what on earth is out so I wonder did
some digging I first of all went and
what I stole Dave Prowse was copy of the
new hackers dictionary although this one
doesn't actually have anything that
might tell us what it is we've got alpha
particles all elbows I'm not come across
that before that's probably worth a
computer file at some point and then
it's aliasing so we don't seem to have
anything on old some loops there so I
sort of did a bit more digging and
fortunately Eric Raymond who wrote that
has a version of it the jargon file on
his website which does cover the
Alderson loop so I can explain a bit
about what it is and why it comes from a
loop in computer software basically it's
trying to do the same code multiple
times until some condition is met or
while some condition is true you can
write it either way you can say we pick
this until this condition is met or
while this condition is true do these
operations and there's various reasons
wanting to do that you can also set that
so that it happens an infinite number of
times ie it keeps looping and looping
and looping and looping and looping and
looping and loop but we in the halting
problem world here not really because
you may want it to loop forever so for
example if you write a network server
what you'll probably do at some point is
say loop forever answering connections
from the network and then you'll just
kill the president we wanted to stop you
don't particularly want your there to be
some condition that can be reached that
will kill a network server a web server
because someone might force that
condition to happen but the oldest and
loop is a variation on the infinite loop
and it sort of combines both loops and
infinite loops but also a bug in the
code so as we said we can write infinite
loops that we want to happen but the
oldest and loop it's a specific type of
infinite loop where if you look at the
source code for the program then it's
obvious that the programmer didn't
intend this to be an infinite loop there
is some part of the source code for the
program that would stop the loop
some circumstances but due to the way
the rest of the program was implemented
it's not possible for that exit
condition to ever be reached so while
there is a way out of the loop there's
no way for the program to ever reach
that point of the code because of other
things in the program
the classic example apocryphally that
calls it to rename this was at the
programmer name of Alderson created a
dialog box in Microsoft Access that had
code that if you clicked ok would make
it disappear but it didn't have an OK
button so you could never click OK so
you couldn't get rid of the dialog box
and so on so it's a it's an infinite
loop where the programmers put code in
that should make it exit but for some
reason this code can't exit in the
current way it's running I guess you
could get it for example if someone is
checking for a key on the numeric keypad
to be pressed but you're running on a
laptop which doesn't have a numeric
keypad so you can't press that key at
all or something so yeah that's what the
obvious and loop is yeah I mean you
basically you could write code that I
mean let's give it
I mean let's give it a go let's find a
computer where we can quickly write some
program so get an implemented program
where they're sort of example of what
might cause an old erson loop so let me
just switch into BBC basic so I can
knock something up relatively quickly so
let's just start going into mode 12
Aurelio's gonna write a program that
enables people to vote on their favorite
well let's get for their favorite
computer file presenter and then
eventually you'll be able to press
another key to go and see what the
results of that would be we'll start by
creating a very simple for loop which
clears off the initial votes I'm having
to remember my BBC basic it's been about
30 years since I last coded it in anger
but we're getting there I've got to make
sure I get this right so I get the right
sort of loop condition in there well if
I can figure out have to get it over the
air connect onto a machine that can
upload it over the ethernet on to get
you
if anyone's got a github client for
riscos please let me know so we've got a
program here which enables us to vote
for our favorite computer file presenter
and we've got three options and if we
run the program we've got three options
we can vote for Dave Brailsford and I
think quite a few people like Dave's or
give them a few votes we can vote for me
and we can break from Mike pounds but we
can also press 0 to see the vote
graphics and if I press 0 oh I'm stuck
in this lead it's not recognizing that
as an exit condition well then we can
still vote we're still at the point Oh
someone's worried for my oh it doesn't
even let you vote for Mike so might be a
bit of favoritism in the voting his
system here it might be rigged but we
can't get out of it unless we hit escape
to kill the program now why is this
happening well if we look at our code
and let's go into a mode where we could
see a bit more on screen at once we've
got the code here so we're printing out
the display at the top which is the sort
of who do we want to vote for and
instructions then we print out the
prompt present the key to vote we read
in the keys and the get commanded BBC
basic we then print it out and we then
loop until we've got a valid value I one
that's greater than zero and one that's
less than three then we set the votes in
the vote array converting it from ascii
to an integer offset into wrote that
we've created there and increment it by
1 so we do this until we get the key
code that represents the letter 0 we do
have a negative condition for this loop
because we're saying repeat this the
whole of this until the key code that's
perfect we've got in the variable 8% is
equal to the ASCII code for 0 but we
also have this loop here between lines
160 and 200 that check that the key
that's been pressed is one of the valid
options what we're trying to do here is
make sure we've got a valid option
before we try and update the values for
the votes otherwise we'd crash the
program or at least get an error message
from the basic interpreter a person has
to be greater than the ASCII code
zero and less than the ASCII code for
three this bit of the code means that
this exit condition could never be
reached because it says that the ASCII
code has to be greater than zero and so
if to end that loop it has to be greater
than zero it cannot be equal to zero at
this point so we've effectively created
a program with a very simple older son
Luke and a little book which means no
one can vote for Mike
lightly right